signori vi spiego una roba velocissima
io odio quando lascio il gameplay
incompleti the witch house è un rpg ad
esempio tipo a o amici hanno fatto un
paio di episodi ma tipo nel 2013 quindi
secoli fa e non l'avevo mai continuato
perché avevo perso i salvataggi quindi
iniziamo oggi the witch house cioè
questa bambina che si risveglia nella
foresta ma posso già muovermi perfetto
poi c'è un gatto gatto nero ci siamo
svegliate che botta tu ci hai preso ieri
sera gava tu hai finito di mangiare le
crocchette a posto di totti mangiarli
crocchette regali cosa punto io uscirei
dalla foresta volentieri me ci sono dei
fiori la via è bloccata da un cespuglio
di rose incredibilmente grande anni non
posso superare un muro di rose bene
abbiamo appurato che il sistema di mura
attorno alle prigioni non serve a niente
basta metterle rose la gente non passa
25 gatto è sparito a è sparito lunga
tavolo so che correre ma figata lo
sapevo la via bloccata da un mucchietto
linosa va bene mi fate fare qualcosa in
questo gioco devo fissarle rosa e per
tutto il tempo come maru già in centro è
tutto bloccato regala che doveva c'è una
roba che luccica la vedo a ecco ho
trovato qualcosa di ruggito e affilato
prendi loro aiuto machete allora ma
posso mn alle rose oggetti machete tagli
alle rose non riesci nemmeno a scarpi a
farci lunghezza delle rose la via è
libera benissimo il machete si è rotto o
[ __ ] 2 euro su amazon l'hai comprato
sto machete ma che schifo
dai che mi serviva un arma per
difendermi porca eva
buongiorno accigliato salve come sa che
c'è so niente stai solo parlando quindi
c'è una botta incredibile così la via
d'uscita bloccata dalle rose ha
intenzione di entrare beh che cosa devo
fare se non quello tanto vale sono puoi
andartene apre al gatto salva la partita
sfigata io entrassi entrambi permesso
siamo in the witch house questa è la
casa della strega bella simpatica
permesso c'è del sangue per terra devo
camminare in questo punto secondo me no
quindi non devo camminare su quanto e
crudo sto gioco brace ma ho ricordato
che si va beh
facciamo finta parte che c'era una roba
che ho visto che si allontanava posso
guardare
vieni nella mia stanza anche senza fini
non tocchiamo il robot ii neo avanti
salve gatto
io mi domando se british ho deciso di
seguirti per farmi due risate e comunque
da dove cavolo sei spuntata fuori dal
sito che impianto che parla tra i 266
google strano è però veniamo dico la
sinistra o delle forbici sono un paio di
forbici di sul banco da lavoro prendi
sono incatenati al banco di sopra sto
punto è bloccata non posso fare niente
destra
[Musica]
andate sempre destra si punte di berna
vabbè e posso orsacchiotti nel cesto
grazie di avermelo scritto che non
l'avevo capito nel cesso sorge un grande
sacchetto è rimasto un po di spazio che
i filati cipro 2
non so non capito oddio un pendolo un
grande orologio il tempo scorre anche
pieno di ovvietà oggi è grazie di
specificarne queste cose perché non
avevo capito un orsacchiotto giace
vicino ai regali prendilo ok
così abbiamo per un natale paranormale e
non toccherò poi il pacco è stato sta
chiedendo diario da strega leggi ero
malata quindi nessuno giocava con me c'è
l'influenza chiama dice mio padre mia
madre non mi volevano bene
questo è un problema più grande a fini
basta toccante questo argomento proprio
posso andare a mettere lo stacchetto
quando era tua destra
ok nel cesso c'è un grande assente
rimasto un pò di spazio ai mezzi e ho 68
i suoi arti non lo fanno in tre non ce
lo fanno entrare soldi agli devo
tagliare sul banco ho già capito che
bello non staccare le braccia non sacchi
8 mi piace questo gioco questo per tutte
le volte che mi avete fatto spaventare
con gli orsacchiotti negli horror [ __ ]
ancora tagli agli arti della nostra
kyoto
hai tagliato gli arti della nostra
chiotto e ho tenuto un corso di
orsacchiotto donna che triste non fate
domande di avanti lecter mai c'è una
lettera alimentare un nuovo vista
dispiace che tu vada a casa sua ma stai
lontana dalla foresta spero di rivederti
a casa presto papà non l'amore in vista
saletta la prima vabbè torsoli
orsacchiotto metti nel cesto e mi senti
qualcosa sbloccarsi da qualche parte
credo che sia la porta quale prima
giusto si proteggano tonache cagà
minchia non me l'aspettavo mai non ha
anche salvato la partita ma darò a
cagare belga ha fatto niente in tutto ed
ha un orsacchiotto formato gigante
perché s'è incazzato che ha tagliato gli
arti a quello piccolo
vorrei salvare la partita
[Musica]
cavalca laida non ci passa qua è troppo
grosso luca sarà andato bene tu non far
niente tranquillo quanto voglio io
perché le forbici sono sporchi di sangue
alla fine faccia veramente gli articoli
così ci sono artigli orsacchiotto per
terra prendi ha raggiunto gli arti dello
scià chiotto la porta si è aperta bene
la donna reagan che ansia esiste roba
nostra la zuppa in una ciotola forma di
teschio di sta roba passaggio al veleno
ma tra madre non assaggia l'aveva la
bevanda know il baby veleno come lo dice
pure che veleno mazzuca il cuoco è
occupato dagli una mano e ha già un paio
di artici gli occhi devo fare un insetto
schifoso ce ne sono due
salve signor cuoco invisibile
c'è qualcuno di invisibile li parla a
sono occupato tanto occupato da una mano
tiene o grazie la persona invisibile
afferrato braccia spinge il tuo corso
sul tagliere no non ci credo non ci
voglio credere
una mano è proprio ciò che mi serviva
nel modo di dire non sei simpatico però
vabbè senti cannavacciuolo libro
titolato cena dagli aristocratici gli
utensili in argento cambiano colore con
a contatto col veleno e diventano
abbastanza utili grazie del consiglio ci
serve una mano prendi con l'orsacchiotto
passa agli altri rosse kyoto o grazie mi
serviva proprio una mano o due
lascia che ti mostri mio apprezzamento
ai tenuto chiave d'argento bene
posso entrare qui la chiave non entra
work hoc che schifo o la chiave
d'argento appena eletto che si può
mettere nel veleno colpisci lasciato
l'aveva chiave metterci nella zuppa
[Musica]
la chiave diventata nera senti qualcosa
sbloccato come se la chiave bluetooth
va bene ho visto qualcosa nel camino
prima di controllare va da sé aveva
partito anzi semmai orco demonio es di
merda un tavolo su cui era un vaso eve
la porta si è aperta bene aspettati ora
gamma cuoco cook è sparito cioè era
sparita anche prima però è sparito di
più di prima vabbè andiamo avanti
salve e lei the witch
speriamo di no o c'è il gatto grazie a
dio un ornamento a forma di gatto
fregata simpatia va bene è un
personaggio con corazza lancia sembra si
possa muovere in ogni momento però non
si muoverà perché noi siamo pacifici
è bloccata c'è una piccola scritto sulla
porta salva la farfalla ok omar on
ok teche di vetro contiene quella che
sembra una testa umana la teca si è
rotta a questa la farfalla c'è una linea
di farfalle con le ali blu nella teca
prendi e fortunate che non si muove ok
la piccola libreria manca un libro
niente sul retro ma che problemi hanno
quelli che abitano qua scusa quella che
abita quale which madonna che anzi ogni
volta un'enciclopedia per bambini sugli
animali ma è il muro è macchiato di
rosso di appiccicoso una storia buffa
c'era una volta un uomo ricco che
trascinava un carrello pieno di
ricchezze il suo carrello si ruppe nei
boschi mali passarono un cacciatore di
il suo cane lo morico chiese al
calciatore di tenere d'occhio suo
carrello il calciatore fu d'accordo
l'uomo ricco andò a prendere un nuovo
carrello nel frattempo il cacciatore
continuava a sorvegliare la notte scese
in fretta e cacciatore inizia a
preoccuparsi per la sua anziana madre
ancora in casa
così i cacciatori di saccani di
sorvegliare il carrello quando a casa a
controllare la madre quando l'uomo tornò
vide già c'era arcane coi soldi tutto
british controllo torno fin dai chiari
di guardia così diede al cannes una
ricompensa per il suo padrone una moneta
d'argento che portò in bocca il cane
corsa a casa e portamento al suo padrone
ma il cacciatore si infuriò cedete di
sorvegliare il carrello ti sei fatto ne
hai rubato una moneta così il padrone
uccise il cane e cazzo rini [ __ ] ma
erano così ma è bellissimo stacce bello
bello finché non mi via infarti povero
cane mi dispiace che ancora sta porta
che non ho controllato tra tutte
poi c'è la farfalla tante farfalle ci
sono il suo gioco c'è un pezzo ricorda
nel barile
avete avuto un po di corda ok il ragno
non vede molto bene non riesce nemmeno a
distinguere i colori che senso una
libreria in poi varata piena di
ragnatele niente di importante qui devo
fare quello che devo fare
vorrei stessa gente
no no non è vero scherzavo non si apre e
quindi ragazzo livelli si conclude qui
il primissimo episodio di the witch
house spero vi sia piaciuto a me sta
piacendo un bordello non lo ricordavo
fosse così figo scegliamo prossimo
episodio lo faccio uscire molto prima di
quanto pensiate perché ho capito che non
devo far passare a settimana da un
episodio all'altro se non vi ricordate
una mazza giustamente e io flexo da
ragazzi no non lo faccio che 700 euro di
telefono anche no dai
[Musica]